mais là je pense que c'est une jeune
femme très forte presque viril mais je
pense aussi qu'elle est très sensible
dans sa banlieue
certains lui reprochent de faire des
études en lui disant tu vas te taper des
années d'études mais avec ton nom tu
arriveras jamais à trouver du boulot
ge est en retard ça va je vais arriver
avec cinq minutes de retard pourquoi
vous vous acharnez sur moi comme ça
alors voilà le complexe de persécution
qui pourrait peut-être typique et puis
il ya pire bazar son professeur de droit
qui a l'art de la provocation il est
assez digne matic parce qu'on sait pas
grand chose sur lui on rencontre un type
qui est presque la caricature de lui
même mais qui a l'amour de son métier
qui a l'amour malgré tout des autres
pour communiquer pour transmettre son
savoir je pense que c'est un gars
qui dérape qui provoque et ça va la
heurter lui faire très mal donc
forcément elle veut rien savoir de ce
type
l'un comme l'autre sont contre l'idée
d'avoir besoin de l'autre sauf qu'ils se
rendent compte donc pas vraiment le
choix
ils sont l'un à côté de l'autre épaule
contre épaule et ils sont obligés
d'avancer ensemble mais ils font aussi
un chemin l'un vers l'autre main qui est
assez assez vous ces deux personnages
vont apprendre à se connaître et à
s'apprécier à faire ensemble
d'hésitation et très vite ils vont se
rendre compte que en fait c'est une
super idée
[Musique]